- My name is Olivia Abtahi.
I'm 30 years old.
I'm a film director,
and I make approximately $80,000 a year.
I currently work at a video
production company here
in Colorado called Mightier.
I do a range of things.
Sometimes I'm directing.
Sometimes I'm editing.
Other times, I'm creating
storyboards or scripts
or just coming up with
concepts for clients,
and then a lot of it is
just meeting with clients,
talking to them, making
sure everything's on track
and that we're getting their vision right.
Yeah, I think when you're
in a small business,
you kind of have to wear a ton of hats.
It's not one of those jobs
where everything is very siloed,
and you have just one job,
and that's what you have the focus on.
I think I'm lucky in that I
get to touch a lot of things
at work because if I can
set up the storyboard
for success, that way when
I'm on set later, you know,
I'm so grateful to be
Olivia of two months ago
where I set myself up for success,
and then, you know, going
into post production, as well,
making sure I'm slating in properly,
so just being thorough in every stage,
because there's a very good
chance I'll have to deal
with it later.
I have had 10 internships,
and I have been working in
this industry for 10 years,
and this is now my first full paying job
where I actually have benefits and I know
when my next paycheck is going to come in.
I cannot even tell you
the amount of thankless,
grubby jobs I have done
to get to where I am now,
and I think it's important to remember
that whoever you're working for or,
if you're just starting
out, the person whose maybe
in charge of your project,
has also paid those same dues.
The people who might be a little
higher up than you have had
a lot of experience doing these things,
and it's important to
just learn from them,
and instead of talking so much,
just remember to listen
first and foremost.
My long-term goals are to get signed
with a larger production company
where I am just working
whenever I win a bid,
and that would mean
probably working less hours,
but the stakes are so much higher
because that's maybe my
only job for the month,
and then my goal is to
have a job like that
where I am may be working one
out of every four weeks a month,
that lets me focus on my own projects.
My ultimate plan is to take
all of these work opportunities
and positions to get
better at being a director
and alternately create
my first feature film.
If you are interested in
being a film director,
then my first piece of advice
is going to be to just shoot,
just shoot your own movies.
There is no reason why
you can't make a film
with the tools that you have.
There are so many wonderful
films now being shot
on an iPhone,
and if you have an
iPhone or a smart phone,
that means you have what
it takes, equipment wise,
to make a feature film.
So grab your friends.
You know, find a weekend,
and just make stuff happen
because you won't learn
as much about directing
from a book or from a website
as you will than just being
on a shoot and trying to
make your dream come true.
I will say some of the pitfalls, though,
are that it's hard to get validation.
It's hard to get recognition
because there are so many
other filmmakers out there,
and you really just have
to find your own voice.
In the beginning, you might be
trying to copy other artists,
and like, that's understandable
because you're trying to
figure out your style,
but I would say find your voice.
Find the movie that you want to watch,
and make sure that you're
the one who makes it.